worked you could see in analyzing that  zone  cutting half again look at this right  here  let's just now he's going to step back  between the legs step back  under control squeeze the body be man  watch this right here look at the  patience he's gonna go in here  he's gonna win he's gonna spin he's  impatient poised and then points  patience cunningham  he puts oklahoma state back on top with  under 40 seconds to go what a  performance we're seeing  what a clutch performance is loaded with  talent austin reeves  [Applause]  is  who's on the line right now cunningham  has been  absolutely better than advertised he's  been super scintillating sensational